[Music]
that man you there
little help okay Sam remove the pod and
connect it to that incubator it's in
good temporary excessive stress easily
addressed if we return it to its
mother's womb mother located in the
capital not City I see you bring that of
course you means still mother correct a
steal mother's womb facilitates a
connection between the world of the dead
and the BB and you in turn connect
yourself to a BB granting you the
ability to sense Metis
these parts were designed to simulate
the conditions inside a steel mother's
womb babies need to believe they're in
one at all times to function properly
however we can only maintain this
deception for so long which is why we
must periodically update the
environmental data by synchronizing it
with a steel mother via the chiral
network there the update is in progress
right now the art is synchronizing with
the steel mother in capital not City and
reconfiguring its settings based on the
latest data returning your bebe to the
womb in this manner will temporarily
reduce its stress levels that being
where it technically belongs of course
it looks happy now try adjusting the
oxytocin dosage how to toxemia shook
teddy much lower for now on you should
remember that babies are just equipment
try not to get attached each one has
been physically removed from its steel
mother's womb a process that renders
them unpredictable and prone to failure
no BB on record has remained in service
for over a year it may need to be
retired before this expedition is over
and then you saying there's no way to
keep my baby alive you must understand
there is still a great deal we don't
know about babies as we expand the
chiral Network and recover more past
data perhaps we'll find our answers
please